- What's up Gary?
No, I'm playing man.
Good to see ya dude.
- [Gary] Good to see ya.
I remember when I
first met you, I'm like oh,
somebody in tech
that likes sports?
I was like so... Like...
- [Alexis] Not that kinda way.
- Well, that's
what I like the best.
ESPN ate kind of
like Sports Illustrated
and the local news and sports,
and then I really think
Bleacher Report disrupted ESPN.
And now, if you look,
I really think Bar Stool is
disrupting Bleacher Report,
and I think it's happening
because of podcasting.
So to me what's
interesting about publishing,
is like when the mediums change,
what are the white spaces?
So a lot of what I'm
thinking about with The Gallery,
and PureWow being the
first brand under it
is so I actually... There's
another thing which is like,
I love nostalgia, so I actually
want ... When I bought PureWow,
I was like,
"I'm gonna buy (censored),
"and then reframe it as
if it was built in 2020."
I think for me, what
I really want to accomplish
in this hour, is,
I want to reverse,
so unlike 99 percent...
Like if you look at
every person that's at Cannes,
how many people,
here, actually knew what
Y Combinator was the first year?
Two or three?
- [Alexis] No one.
- Correct.
I think I far
more likely am capable
of creating the
offers and the partnerships
than any of my contemporaries
because I think I'm independent,
I'm more grounded in it,
and I just have
more heart for it.
It's like to me, it's
really as basic as that,
I genuinely
believe that you guys
are a very
important pillar of culture,
is probably the
way I would put it,
And I have a lot of confidence
because much like social,
anything that I get deeper into,
inherently the
agency gets better at,
because I can
create the strategy
and so as I am doing my thing,
I'm not only doing my AMA's,
just kind of like
digging deeper into the content,
things of that nature.
So I want to first kind of
hear, like what are the wants
or needs or dreams
that people were doing,
or what kind of
partnerships do you want,
because maybe you're
still early and hacking it too,
so maybe you don't know
exactly how you want it,
but I'd like to
listen for a few minutes
to the State of the Union, or
like the wants, dreams, hopes.
- Two years ago, Steve and I
came back to Reddit full-time.
Imagine for the seven years
we were gone, nothing changed.
- [Gary] Makes sense.
The only thing that changed was
the site doubled
every year in traffic,
but the product didn't change,
the business didn't change,
it was like frozen in time.
and any other
company should have died,
but thankfully, it kept growing,
and so when we came
back now two years ago
We found
something that basically
was like coming
back to an old house
Or like coming back
to your childhood room,
where nothing's changed.
Except now it's way
more popular and influential,
but the last two years
have been like hitting reset.
And now finally
building all this shit
we would have built seven
years ago if we hadn't left.
("Born Hustler" by Rowlan)
- David and Alexis, you
guys don't know each other?
- No.
- Alexis is the
co-founder of Reddit.
- [David] Oh, okay
David Levy is the
president of Turner.
- [Alexis] Right on.
- Alexis is a
huge Red Skins fan.
- Yeah.
- Sorry about that buddy.
- [Alexis] It's all right,
it earns character.
- It turns though.
I've been a Packer fan for
years, and now, finally ...
Now when I say years,
Lynn Dickey, you know, crap team
all the way to (mumbles),
you know, it turns.
- Magic Man?
- [Alexis] Majkowski.
- Remember?
- [Alexis] Yeah, that too.
- All those shitty years.
- [Alexis] No,
but that's exactly
why you're a fan,
it pays off. When I was--
- Hold on, hold on Levy.
- What?
- How old are you?
- 55.
- Right, so what
year did Favre take over?
91 ... 93 ... 92-93, right?
So what's that?
We haven't had a good run since.
That's, yeah, this
is where I'm going.
This is 24 years, right?
Yeah.
- I've had a good run.
- A good run?
- Remember, I was (mumbles).
- You guys have
been good for 24 years,
you've been in the mix.
- [Alexis] It's the last
year we were good.
- This entire
like ecosystem here
is completely a
B to B environment.
This entire thing here,
like agencies
want to win an award
because they get more business.
Brands want to win an award
because it gives them air cover
to do the
things they want to do,
and it completely
has nothing to do...
Like, normal human
beings don't know this exists.
Like your friends that are
your neighbors don't realize
this week is happening.
This is not the
Academy fucking Awards.
So I think that, yeah.
- But we do like being here.
- Yeah, it's a
very pretty place,
but I think that there's,
I'd love to hear his no,
I mean inherently
advertising as we've known it
for the last 50-60 years,
and why innovation is so
interesting, and I agree.
When I say dead,
the monetization
of breaking up content
in a TV environment,
to his point,
if we evolve with the times.
Nintendo was a
playing card company.
That business
might have been dead.
They've evolved
over the last 70 years
into the company they are.
I think anything
that stops the human being
from doing what
they actually want to do,
is inherently a bad thing,
in a world where
technology is rapidly innovating
to allow people to
have a better experience.
I'll give you the best,
I mean, I literally couldn't
have made this up.
I get off the plane here,
I'm in line in customs,
it takes two seconds, we all
just did it, in Cannes right?
It takes two seconds.
But I'm in line, two
people behind me, and I hear,
because I'm obsessed
right now with voice.
Alexa Skills, podcasting,
just voice as an arbitrage
to save time.
I think the reason we're seeing
the growth of these things,
is it saves time.
Literally, the two people,
non-American,
not English speaking,
but speaking in
English with accents
from outside markets, in just
an interesting conversation,
the lady says to the guy,
"So wait a minute, you know,
"search is going to
get redefined with Alexa,
"like give me the answer."
She goes, "How are we
going to get ads in there?"
And he goes,
"Yeah, it's annoying."
(audience laughter)
And I was laughing because
I was like, "Said not one
"consumer in the world,
"but said these two
ad-tech executives."
- Thank you.
(audience applause)
- How are you? Such a pleasure.
- Great to meet you.
- Thank you.
Thank you so much.
- We gotta get a
picture together though.
- We will definitely do it.
Wanna do that,
yeah let's do that?
- We gotta do it right now.
- Yes!
- I love it.
- Good, thank you man.
- Thank you so much.
- Alright, what
are you doing tonight?
- I don't know,
but I'll text you.
- Look at that picture.
- You didn't get asked?
- I never get asked.
- I get it, I get it, I get it.
- So now I believe that
education has to change.
I just want to
show you my little
what I'm creating
with a friend of mine.
So it's about coding, and I want
to get them in all the schools.
- [Shonduras] Killing it, dude,
thanks for everything!
- Of course.
- Thanks for the shouts,
that was good stuff.
I like how you
went into eSports there.
- I know what you're doing.
It's true though, man.
We live in a different
universe than they live in.
- Got it.
- Even watching
you and Alexis react
to television's the only reach.
Like it's like
glossed over faces.
You guys are like--
- Yeah, yeah.
- You don't even understand.
It's not even that you disagree.
You don't even understand the
words that are being said.
- Yeah, literally was
confused as like
how is the best reach right now?
I like what you said
about the Super Bowl,
that was interesting.
- Yeah Super Bowl
commercials, I'm all in.
- Yeah.
- All in.
- Top team in North America
right now, already.
- Keep doing your thing.
Proud of you.
- I'm ready,
I'm ready, I'm ready.
- Here, he has a
message for you guys.
- The fact that
you're smart enough to
follow Baldwin
means you already know,
but as much hustle
as you're deploying,
triple-down on that shit.
- BAM!
- Harder.
- Uh!
- Damn!
- Bam.
- That's the
internet right there.
("Born Hustler" by Rowlan)
- Cooper, I'm listening,
I'm talking
when I have the mic,
but when I'm an executive,
all I do is listen.
I'm trying to
reverse-engineer and fix,
I feel like I'm in
the fixing business.
Like, what's the issue and
I'm the last line of defense
and that's not going to fix it.
- And you've got to get
the other people to rise.
- 100%.
- Because you're not doing it.
- But the best way
to get people to rise
is to have them
heard at all levels.
The best way to
have a great leader,
great management, is
to give a shit about them
which then forces
and suffocates them
to give a shit
underneath and you talk to like
Steve as our chief
creator, or like Kim,
they'll tell you, I put
a lot of pressure on
you better be
managing underneath you
the way I manage you.
- Right.
- Because when
I hear everyone stress,
I don't do that to you.
I don't stress any of you.
I don't P&amp;L any of you,
so why the hell
are you doing like,
if you're manifesting
your own thing,
I'm empathetic to that,
that's a human trait.
But, let's talk that through.
So, anyway,
I'm just in the business of
having a 15-minute
meeting when I get back
where it's like,
Karen is complaining
that Susie is ruining her.
- Uh-huh.
- I'm into that, I like it.
And I don't like it
because I'm a yenta,
I like it because
that's how you fix a company.
It's how you
build a good company.
- Well your
company is people, right?
And we talk about
IP, but it's people.
- My company is people,
in the cliche agency world,
every company is people.
I think you guys are
sitting on gold because
business and
entrepreneurship is as true
as American pie and what I love
is watching you
guys as media companies
trump each other
always based on who's right.
Who's right?
Cosmo is right to
do that Snapchat deal.
You, Inc., Entrepreneur,
or, whoever else, Forbes,
somebody is going to
make the best podcast and win.
And sell more
magazines because of it.
That's going to happen.
One of you is going
to make the best
Alexa Skill that's going
to own the morning brief
and you're going to win.
Somebody's going to
create the video blog,
you guys should make the news.
What was the show
that Sorkin wrote for--
- [Woman] Newsroom.
- Newsroom.
You guys should
literally do what I do.
If you guys made a Fast Company,
you guys share, right?
- Mhmmm.
- If you guys did a show,
this is not a joke,
if you guys did a vlog
of your office everyday,
in a year, you
would be 20-50% up
on all revenue
things that matter.
If you guys
literally did The Office
meets Newsroom
meets Casey's vlog.
Everyday, on Facebook,
(inaudible), your show.
And you're the
executive producer.
So it's not like
anything gets out
that you don't want out.
It's powerful,
redefining the media.
I basically built this
company on giving stuff away.
- Yeah.
- I'm a big believer,
people always think,
fuck that, it's a
gateway into business.
I think it decides who the
three to five pioneers are next,
you give away some
stuff and you fucking go.
Thanks man!
I gotta leave, right?
- Like, this is the
biggest joke on the planet.
I just don't know what
I'm doing with my life.
And we're in the right
place doing everything right.
I don't know.
- We're going to win.
- But look at this.
Somebody spent
time drawing this.
To explain programmatic
advertising to people
who are reading the
Wall Street Journal.
This is what smart
people are reading.
- Look, everybody
has their romance points.
It's fact, I'm always trying to
suffocate out
romance, it's even the
conversation we had yesterday.
What's that Mendoza Line?
Fuckin', these people make
these movies for $200 million
in costs that
have like $48 in sales.
It's why...
Show her, show her.
So, productive morning, meeting
with one of our great
clients, big breakfast.
So that went super
well, they did a panel
obviously you'll see that
with David Levy
and Bobby S. from Fast Company.
That was super fun.
Now heading and talking
to some young creatives.
Just being
really productive today.
The boat's kind of,
the boat's kind of got
a little fanciness to it.
But it's not a smaller boat.
Thought I'd keep it less fancy.
But just having
a headquarters to
have meetings has been
unbelievably productive.
So I'm excited about that.
We're doing super well so far,
very productive
24-hours in the game.
Getting some business done.
Listen, this is all business.
It's arbitrage, right?
You come here for a week
to save yourself a month.
I'm gonna see 15
to 25 CMOs, CEOs,
that I wouldn't
have seen otherwise.
So that's what I'm
taking advantage of.
That's what I'm focused on.
I'm running late!
- Gary!
- Hey!
- Good, how are you?
- You doing well?
- Yeah, I'm good.
- PR?
Looking forward to it.
- So we met yesterday.
- I remember.
- Are you actually a fight fan?
- Boxing?
- Yeah.
- Huge.
- Okay, so I work at (bleep),
and I'm meeting
tomorrow, actually,
so you should come to
the (inaudible), Triple G fight.
- I would love that.
That would be amazing.
I am massively impressed
and curious how you
guys are thinking about that.
- Great.
- Thank for saying hello,
thanks for asking about that.
- I'm sorry, I.
- That's awesome.
Oh get this, get this.
- Oh, is this a celebrity?
- Is this a
celebrity on the street?
- We're here speaking
to the most overrated CEO
in the market.
- Is this a celebrity?
- Ben Lair.
You've been voted
number one most overrated CEO,
but also in a ton of events,
number one best
looking CEO. (laughs)
How do you feel
about those two statistics?
- Fantastic,
I didn't hear the first one.
(laughs) That's amazing,
what are you doing?
- I'm going to speak.
- Okay, oh I know.
I'm going to Snap.
- Sorry, I follow you!
- Oh thank you!
(laughs)
- I'm Jasmine, nice to meet you!
- [Gary] Hi, nice to meet you.
How are you?
- I'm good, you're cool!
- [Gary] Thank you!
Thank you so much.
- I like what you say.
- [Gary] Thank you so much.
- Yeah, how long
are you in town for?
- Until Friday.
- [Jasmine] Cool, well,
it was nice to meet you!
- [Gary] Nice to meet you,
thanks for saying hello.
- [Ben] Hi.
- Hi.
- Okay, love you.
- I love you.
- Go talk and I'll see you.
- Text me.
Please, it would make me
happy, I want to do it for you.
It'd be a nice little gift.
- I appreciate that.
- You're welcome.
- Don't get crazy,
don't go Louis Vuitton on me.
(laughs)
- Yeah, I'll go
right to the market!
- Dude I really hurt my ankle.
- [DRock] What'd you do?
- Yesterday I hurt my ankle.
Met a lot of
salespeople that ain't got
natural marketing DNA and
vice versa and if you notice,
the people that are successful,
if you
stripe away their ability
to be political
with an organization,
they're the marketing person
that the salespeople respect,
or that a salesperson
that the market people respect.
I think those are people
that actually have what I have,
so I don't think
I'm some unicorn.
- Yeah.
- I think there's a
lot of people who actually
have the ability to be
good at sales and marketing.
I think companies force you
to go one route or the other
and then thus we don't
even realize that capability.
So in entrepreneur-land,
we see it.
We see it less in organizations.
I consume nobody.
I create content, I consume
my audience's response to it,
and stay in my vortex.
And I like to innovate
and hack, and I think,
I'm actually
scared to consume others,
because I think it unroots me,
and so I just stay
in my little cocoon.
- Appreciate it.
- You got it.
How are you?
- Awesome, thanks for coming!
- Of course.
- [Man] If you
could just give me some
reasonings and
what, why do you say,
or what makes you
think that 25 minutes
or maybe beyond, what
is your thoughts on that?
How does 25 minutes
become an engaging or,
because it's all numbers
when you come to digital.
You can track
numbers pretty much,
who dropped on when and
what minutes and whatever.
- You know what's
amazing about creative,
from my
perspective as an entrepreneur?
Is when Vine was
getting going, right?
I'd broken out as a YouTube
star, so when I saw Vine,
I'm like, oh shit,
here it is again.
I went hardcore.
I like signed Jerome Jarre,
and Karen Dallas,
and Nash Grier,
like I knew all of them,
like I signed them,
I was like I don't know what
I'm going to do with them,
but there's something here.
But you know what I learned,
through that
phase that excited me?
Is that, if you make a
shitty six-second Vine,
people are gone in two seconds.
And I think if Star Wars
announced tomorrow
that they're making a five
hour 18 minute Episode VIII,
the world would cheer.
Like if you make great
product, people will consume.
- [Man] But do you think,
will they not switch
to a Netflix then a Facebook?
That kind of content
which has had--
- Sure, I mean look.
So one thing I think
people aren't good at,
is understanding
formant changes.
So Facebook has
technology right now,
that allows you to go
from feed, right to the screen.
Like right now, in 24 months
the majority of you
will take your phones,
see something and literally
flick it to here.
So you're thinking in the
way the world is right now.
So you're thinking
longer form, higher quality
makes more sense in
a Netflix environment
than it does in a
Facebook environment.
I know that
everybody's gonna be agnostic,
and on big screen.
Right, so got it?
So to me, what you're doing
is you're taking this moment,
and you're
deploying where do we see
higher quality
things of that nature?
Which is ironic in itself,
because if you went to
Hollywood four years ago,
they were shitting on Netflix.
Right?
So like it's very fascinate,
by the way HBO,
the one thing that
I recommend to all youngsters is
do history, right?
Like, all these things, HBO
was low brow quality content,
like it's amazing to watch it,
all you need is that execution.
So to me, the one
great thing about creatives,
is it is the punch
line of the whole thing.
I just want to support mediums
that give it more expression.
And I'm a businessman, so I
understand the 30 second spot,
and the 15 second spot,
and to discuss to
have around programatic,
I understand why it's happening,
it's the economics of
scale to run businesses.
But it doesn't
take away the fact
that those are not the best
experiences for the customer,
and what technology
does is suffocate out.
It's funny.
("Born Hustler" by Rowlan)
(group laughter)
Awesome! Thank you.
Yeah, I'm going to
put that, I'm always,
I don't know if
you guys know this,
I do a vlog every day
on YouTube and Facebook,
so some of this will be here
and then sometimes
we'll take the whole thing
and put it as a separate piece.
Probably.
- I was really
inspired by what you said
about like when you're
correct, like sticking to it.
- Yes.
- And not conforming.
And like I, this year I
did that a lot at my school.
- Yes.
- Because like
when I was correct like,
even if what I'm doing is
wrong in sight of my teachers
or my fellow students
like, I always stuck to it,
and at the end of the
year it really paid off.
Because I got graduated
on the Honor Roll and stuff
and it was really awesome,
and I was really inspired
about what you said
I just wanted to thank you.
- You're welcome, stick it out.
Yeah, for sure.
Take care, thank you.
(woman drowned
out by crowd chatting)
Be historically correct.
Thank you, bye, thank you.
Bye guys. Have a great
rest of your day. Bye-bye.
- [Man 2] Gary, so
I was listening to you,
and I spoke with you.
- [Gary] Thank you.
("Born Hustler" by Rowlan)
- I think the bigger
question is what,
you can't an idea public.
You have to put an idea
into something that is taken.
You're like I don't know how
to get people to the water.
You have to put
it in this container.
Once the container
that you put that energy to,
I've done it in
a personal brand.
I've done it in an agency.
I've given my passions
and points of view buckets.
You can do that by putting,
when I decide to build a
business next, a product,
it's going to be huge.
'Cause I'm going to be
at the prime of my career,
and I'm going to execute it.
So you just need to
figure out how and what you want
to execute it against.
Do you want to
be a thought leader?
Do you want to be,
do you want it to be a book?
Do you want it to be an agency?
(question off camera)
They wouldn't unless
you get them to read it.
Or they wouldn't and
you would end up like
all of the other books
or you could start
the process of, I mean,
you know who I am.
I've shown you the blueprint.
You can start
producing content at scale
and over the
next year and a half
build enough of a
base that gives you a chance
for a lot of people to read it.
- If something has
felt off in the industry
but we're so like in the
day-to-day that we don't
even realize that it is
and then you hear something
and you're like oh, my God.
We have all these moves
that we don't think about.
- [Gary] Because it
becomes your norm.
- [Woman 2] Yeah.
- It's like citizens
in communist countries.
- [Woman 2] Right.
- They know
but they don't know.
Like the thing that
people don't realize is like
15-year-old girls.
Ask every 15-year-old girl
in the world, country,
agnostic, who the five most
famous people are to them.
When they name three people that
are on Instagram and
Snapchat only and YouTube,
four, three, they can still,
Rihanna, I get it.
But I don't think
people understand.
That's what's going to happen
in the advertising industry.
This festival, this
festival in 2023 is going to be
rewarding Facebook
videos, not commercials.
And you know, by the way, like
from a pure creative sense,
they're going to
be so much better.
Do you know how much better
a 3 minute, 18 second video
that inspires you
feels to a 30-second spot?
What commercial
has really gotten you?
It's hard.
("Born Hustler" by Rowlan)
- How are you doing?
- I just told the young
creatives, I was like, look,
if you want to have a
football career, punt Snapchat.
No chance.
- Yeah?
(laughter)
Classic advice right there.
- My ads are up and running.
- Yeah, I know.
They look great. Love it.
Let me know how I can help.
I'm doing a speech now.
I'll see you tomorrow?
- Yes.
- After you're live?
- Yeah. You're good?
- Yeah.
I'll be on black
coffee after that.
- [Gary] That's cool, man.
Be nice to spend some time.
I just had a very weird feeling.
I just looked at that flag at
the advertising association.
I swear to God
I literally, literally,
just in my head said
I'm going to dominate
that fucking
country in three years.
Like over the next three years.
That is such a weird feeling.
That was,
I love that fucking feeling.
That's when I know
good shit's about to happen.
- [DRock] When'd you
have that happen last?
Do you remember?
- I don't want to make it up.
I don't know, guys.
But one thing, like, it happens.
Like covers of magazines,
the TV stuff, like,
you know, like
I basically thought
that I would be on this
Shark Tank or Voice of apps.
Like flat out.
- [DRock] When was that?
Like how long ago?
- Two, three years ago.
Like flat out.
Like when I went to South-By,
when I went to Cannes here
like three, four years ago.
Like five, six years.
Everybody here
is gonna be like...
Like what just
happened with the China thing.
I haven't had that in a while.
I literally looked
at it, and I was like,
I'm going to
dominate that fuckin' country.
("Born Hustler" by Rowlan)
Gary! Hi.
- Hi.
Peter.
- Peter, how are you?
- I'm good. Nice to see you.
- Nice to see you.
- You have your own microphone?
- I do. That's how I roll.
- Is this going
to be a meta thing?
- It's going to be
a very meta thing.
- Okay. A couple
of minutes to setup.
- Yeah.
- Okay?
- You got it.
- I started watching your
videos about two years ago.
I feel that you
probably, at least from my
point of view,
you've blown up a lot
in that time but I used
to watch your stuff back then
and I thought it was amazing.
- Thank you.
- And I mean that genuinely.
- Thank you Gary.
That's very sweet.
I appreciate that, man.
- I just think it was
very straight to the point.
No B.S. and it
just resonated with me.
And, I thought
I would tell you that.
- I appreciate that, man.
The love means a lot to me.
And get the
feedback loop, ya know?
It feeds it, right.
What's this?
I'm like in my nose.
(DRock laughs)
I've never felt more empowered.
It's interesting.
I want to sell oxygen!
(DRock laughs)
That's always been my dream.
This is the modern
day business programming.
A little box is doing live.
A traditional media company
has got 44 vans out there
trying to do the same thing.
This is new versus old
in a ridiculous setting
and a lot of emotions,
money, and propaganda
being pumped
through the systems here.
(mellow music)
- [Man 4] Best guest.
What about the
guest from yesterday?
- You can't argue with him.
- [Man 4] Yesterday's guest.
- Talent. You're good.
- I know but he is the best.
- [Gary] Feelin' good?
Good seeing you.
- [Man 5] I haven't
seen you in forever.
- I love to see you, man.
You well?
- [Man 5] I'm great,
how are you doing?
- Things going super well?
- [Man 5] Things are excellent.
- Good.
You guys are
deeply entrenched in how
you came up but winners evolve.
It's just so obvious,
it's literally buying it.
You've had competitors.
I know both of your
competitors very well
in the last five years.
Some of them want to
hold onto the way it was.
- They were first.
- You know?
Yeah, they're just romantic.
It's only who's best,
and then it's who's romantic,
and who's not.
- It's fitness, it's
like how people are thin,--
- It's just so true, man.
- You just need
to keep adapting.
- Otherwise you get stuck.
- So true.
It's like,
I don't care who's first.
Listen, if people
get to their finish line,
they sell, they get
what they want,
they want to spend
time with their family,
That's life, but
in business, correct.
That's different but in
the game of business,
like, you just
build and iterate.
- How do you spend
your time these days,
what excites you?
- I'm spending
all my time building
the machine of VaynerMedia.
("Born Hustler" by Rowlan)
- [Gary] Yo!
I can't get a hug?
You can't even
respect, you can't even
come and give me a handshake?
Just a handshake,
just a handshake.
That's good.
Alright, get out of here.
- Alright, I want to
give DRock a hug too.
- Alright, alright.
Now turn, and leave.
Leave.
- Peace!
- It's funny, I did an
interview the other day
and somebody asked me,
who, business magazine,
asked me, who is an
entrepreneur that I thought
was doing a good
job or I looked up to
or who had it figured out,
and without any
hesitation, this beautiful,
smart, wildly-dressed
woman to the right of me
was the easy answer for me.
I am one who
loves entrepreneurship,
it's obviously,
as you can imagine,
been so good to me.
And I spend a lot of
time auditing everybody.
But especially entrepreneurs.
How they navigate,
what they do, and
I'm just so impressed
in watching
Rachel navigate Mik Mak
and I see a lot of you
already shaking your head
through sheer
will, hustle, grind,
like I think entrepreneurship
is fire fighting,
it's boxing, it's like who
can take a good punch, right?
Like, how do you
navigate through those days?
And so, I'm just very
honored to co-host this,
especially with so
many people I admire
in the entrepreneur-land
and in the corporate-land
and so I'm just very
thankful that you guys are here.
I hope you enjoy and I'm really
glad to do this with you.
(cheering and applause)
What have you got to say?
I'm off to the MediaLink party
Michael Kassan, the
kind-of like, big event,
networking event,
here at Cannes.
Got a 30-minute ride,
gonna answer your tweets.
What an amazing
entrepreneur Rachel is.
I put her on my Instagram story,
you should follow her.
("Born Hustler" by Rowlan)